Hello, Noel.
Are you excited for Mexican Week?
I'm really excited for Mexican Week,
absolutely pumped.
Although, I don't feel we should make
Mexican jokes, people will get upset.
-What, no Mexican jokes at all?
-I don't think so.
-What, not even Juan?
-Not even Juan.
-Welcome…
-[both] To the Great British Baking Show.
[Matt] This time…
Nerves, man, nerves.
…we're back to full strength…
I think all eyes will be
on me and Abdul after missing last week.
…for a first.
It's Mexican Week.
[Matt] The bakers will battle
with an enriched signature…
Oh, no, they're burnt.
…get into a Mexican standoff
with a street food technical…
Don't go mad, Carole.
…and try to pull off
a dairy-rich extravaganza
in a mucho challenging showstopper.
-[Maxy] Don't want it to collapse.
-Are you worried about your crack?
[opening theme music playing]
[Rebs] All the best, my darling.
I don't know much about Mexican cuisine.
So this is an absolute adventure.
See you in a bit. Good luck.
When someone says Mexican food,
my mind goes only to fajitas.
That's where my knowledge stops.
Mexican food's fun, but Mexican baking?
What do the Mexicans bake?
I did have to research it
'cause you just do the savoury, really.
[Syabira] I love Mexican food,
so I'm looking forward
to baking it in the tent.
Bakers, welcome back
to the tent for Mexican Week.
Now today, Paul and Prue would like you
each to bake 12 individual pan dulce.
Pan dulce or sweet bread
is the collective term
for a whole array of Mexican sweet treats.
Now, your pan dulces should be made
using one of the yeasted varieties
and you should present the judges
with 12 identical tasty buns.
[Noel] Which is also Paul's nickname.
-[Matt] You have two and a half hours.
-[Noel] On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake.
Pan dulce. It means sweet bread.
It's not cake, it's not a bread.
I've never had them before,
so I don't know
how they're supposed to be like.
[Paul] Now what is a pan dulce?
Basically, it's an enriched bread,
an enriched roll.
There are dozens and dozens
of varieties of this,
they change from region to region.
[Paul] Because it's an enriched dough,
it's gonna be slower proving.
They've got to get that dough rising
as quickly as possible.
-[clattering]
-Oh, my God.
Mexico is full of vibrancy,
colour, wonderful food, great flavours,
and that's what we expect
this week from the bakers.
Nerves, man, nerves.
-Hello, Janusz.
-Hello.
Tell us about your pan dulce.
So I've decided to make conchas
and I've decided to
decorate them as little cactuses.
-Cacti.
-Cacti, yes. That is correct.
[Noel] Janusz is making one of the most
popular of pan dulces, known as concha.
It's a sweet enriched roll
with a crunchy craquelin topping.
His coconut-flavoured bread
will be contrasted with a limey crunch.
I'm using plain flour for these.
They were more cakey, which I liked.
So less pan dulce, more cake?
It's gonna be… mix.
You look a little perturbed, Paul.
Interesting. I look forward
to this one. Thanks.
-Thank you.
-Good luck.
[Matt] Janusz is not the only baker
creating conchas
in the form of a Mexican icon.
[Syabira] I'm making
corn-on-the-cob pan dulce.
Corn is very popular in Mexico,
and if I read correctly,
they say it's more than 60 varieties.
-[Noel] Hello, Syabira.
-Hello.
So are you happy about Mexican Week?
-Yeah. Have you been to Mexico?
-Yes, I have.
-Have you done a tequila shot?
-I like tequila. Do you like tequila?
-Yeah. Mexican Week.
-In the morning, yeah?
I do tequila
just to get through this show.
Slam a couple of those down.
-Me and Prue do, yeah.
-[laughs]
[Matt] Celebrating
a vital component of Mexican cuisine,
Syabira's conchas will have
a corn and coconut custard filling
and be decorated
to resemble corn on the cob.
And are you gonna cut each piece
to create the corn look?
-Yeah. I'm using this one.
-[Paul] Right, okay.
Interesting. Okay.
Well, I trust you on the artistic side.
-Look forward to it.
-Thank you.
[Noel] With limited time,
today's challenge is all about
how the bakers ensure their dough
gets enough of a prove.
I'm making sure my ingredients
are already quite warm
to kick-start that proving process.
I've combated my proving time
with timesaver yeast.
It naturally saves time. A new discovery.
The recipe that I've got,
it actually uses
a tiny bit of baking powder.
Think it helps to make it
a bit more like a cake than a bread.
[Noel] Another baker who has opted
for the most popular of pan dulces
is James.
It's gonna be a wee concha number.
It's vanilla and cinnamon and coffee.
I've tried to keep it a bit traditional.
There's some chocolate in the top,
crunchy bit as well.
[Noel] James' soft cinnamon
and coffee concha buns
will have a chocolate
and coffee crunchy top
and he'll create delicate caramel oysters
complete with edible pearls.
'Cause it's based on a shell,
I thought I'd stick with that theme.
-Lovely. Thank you.
-Cheers, see you soon. [chuckles]
That's looking spot on now.
[Matt] Once the dough is made…
Soft and stretchy.
That's my aim, soft and stretchy.
…it is essential
the bakers develop the gluten
or their pan dulces
will be dense and tough.
I have to knead this by hand now.
It could have a bit more liquid.
Feels a bit too tacky-ish.
No Mexican way
of kneading bread I know of.
When Paul's around,
I'll knead it his way. [chuckles]
[Noel] There are over a thousand types
of pan dulces baked in Mexico,
including besos, a romantic little number.
With besos, it refers to as kisses,
where two buns are kissing each other.
[Noel] It's been chosen by Abdul.
In Spanish, besos literally means kisses.
Abdul's buns will come rolled in coconut,
dyed the colours of the Mexican flag
and stuck together
with jam and buttercream.
I searched online
to see what the texture really is
and it's usually a bit more dense.
-It's not very soft bread.
-Really?
-That's what at least--
-I've just come back from Mexico.
-Oh, yeah? Did you have the besos?
-I did.
-Oh, okay. [laughs]
-[laughing]
-Unfortunately, he knows all about it.
-Uh-oh. Yes.
-Good luck, flavours sound lovely.
-Thank you so much.
-Thank you.
-Good luck.
Dough's smooth-ish,
so now I'm going to get it proving
for about 30 minutes.
Dough is looking good,
lovely and stretchy.
About, 25 minutes.
At home, I'd leave it for an hour.
[Noel] With dough
stashed in the proving drawers…
My dough is proving now.
I'm making the topping.
…for those making conchas,
the buns must be topped
with a simple cookie dough.
Almost like a biscuit
and a bread combined, I guess.
[Noel] Like craquelin,
a sugar, butter, and flour mix
must be rolled wafer-thin
before cutting out.
[James] These are just
for the tops of the conchas.
They'll just sit on top as like a wee hat.
[Matt] Sandro's not only making
a concha topping,
but also planning a tasty base.
[Sandro] Mine is gonna be quite sweet
'cause I'm mostly dipping it in caramel
and having some hazelnuts for crunch.
[Matt] Sandro's salted caramel
and coffee conchas
will have a praline custard filling.
They'll be finished off
with a caramel and hazelnut base.
The idea is to do
a salted caramel cappuccino bomb thing.
I'm behind schedule!
[Matt] Having missed Bread Week,
Rebs is determined
to make every second count.
I have everything broken down
to literally the minute
of what I've got to do.
Because today, I'm managing my time.
[Matt] Rebs plans vanilla concha buns
topped with lemon craquelin
and served
with whipped cream lemon curd on the side.
[Noel] Ever done Mexican food?
-[Rebs] Love a nachos night.
-Love a nacho.
Something amazing about Mexico. Magical.
I wanna go
to the Mexican Day of the Dead festival.
[gasps] Yes.
The one place that I'll fit in.
[laughs]
This is aniseed and ground anise.
[Noel] With her pan dulces,
Carole's embracing Mexican flavours.
[Carole] Used typically
in Mexican cooking.
[Noel] Finding the language
rather trickier…
I am making anise and orange de pan.
You're making what, sorry?
Pan de denise?
-Denise? Someone you know or…
-Denise. [laughs]
[Noel] Carole's the only baker
making a pan de anise pan dulce.
A light fluffy Chelsea bun-style bake
will be filled with a zesty orange
and aniseed curd.
-It sounds delicious.
-Sounds great.
-Does it have a name?
-Oh, it's just your anise de pan, I think.
[Matt] There's more than one baker
opting for a tongue-twisting title.
I'll be naming my bake
snap… mella… [laughs]
Bella la… Bella Naranja,
which translates to pretty orange.
[Matt] Maxy's Bella Naranja conchas
will be packed
with orange and cinnamon flavour,
have a crispy topping,
and be served
with cinnamon Chantilly on the side.
Who won Star Baker last week?
Janusz.
-[softly] Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, he got his second Star Baker.
-Is he your main competition?
-He's my best mate.
There's gonna be a point
where you're gonna have to destroy him.
-You know that. [laughing]
-I know, I know.
-[Noel] Across the tent…
-Ugh.
…is one more baker who's making
the most popular of pan dulces.
I'm doing conchas,
erm, and they're conchas with a kick.
[Noel] Dawn's classic Mexican combo
of chocolate and chilli-flavoured conchas
will come with a green and red
craquelin topping.
The flavours sound good.
I like the chilli in the chocolate.
-Yes.
-[Paul] What chilli?
Er, the, er, these ones, bird's eyes.
-How many are you using?
-Quite a few.
-Right.
-[chuckles] Good.
[Matt] Kevin's also
on a quest for big flavour.
I'm making the rum butter. Equal parts
butter and soft dark brown sugar.
[Matt] But rather than go spicy,
he's gone boozy.
'Cause it's baked,
I'll soak it in a rum syrup.
[Matt] Kevin's the only baker
making Mexican borrachitos.
Translated as "little drunkards",
the alcohol-soaked bake
will rest on a desiccated coconut base.
I… I just quite liked
the image of these buns
kind of tottering around
like little drunk people.
So is Mexico a real place?
I think so.
-What?
-I think it's like Xanadu.
Like Oz?
-Yeah, like Cleethorpes.
-Hmm, okay.
Bakers, you are halfway through!
[Sandro] Your dough proved good?
[Abdul] Not as good as it used to at home.
-[Carole] Hmm.
-[Noel] After the first prove…
Soft.
…for those making conchas, shaping is key.
Sort of roll it out,
then you just fold it in on itself.
Fold it over.
Then I like grab them
into a wee ball like this.
And then, voilà.
Just fondling the balls,
you know. [laughing]
They're not the best.
Bit small, some of them.
I can't find my ruler,
so it's a bit of a guessing game.
[Noel] The addition of filling
ups flavour…
[Dawn] We put ganache in the middle,
chocolate and chilli, in that order.
…but runs the risk
of slowing the second prove…
I'm putting the sweetcorn in to just give,
like, the celebration of Mexican flavour.
…as does the trademark concha topping,
if not paper thin.
I'm cutting my cookie crust.
It goes on top.
And then you kind of, like,
hug it around the dough.
And then we're gonna cut them
so it resembles sort of cacti.
[Matt] Scoring the craquelin topping…
Crucial step.
…allows the creation
of elaborate patterns as the dough grows.
[Rebs] Just doing four lines.
[James] Each of these should pop apart
and you get a grid effect on it.
Right. I'm gonna put them
in the proving drawer.
[Carole] There is some
big ones in there, some small ones.
[Matt] With second prove underway…
[Sandro] Okay, babies, grow for me nicely.
…the bakers turn their attentions
to decorative touches.
[Abdul] Besos are usually covered
with desiccated coconut
and I thought, hey, you know what,
why not I mix in the red, green, white,
and kind of make, like, a Mexican flag.
-Right, how's it all going?
-Er, I'm all good so far.
Did you desiccate the coconut yourself?
-No. It was desiccated for me.
-No.
-Cheat! We have a cheat in the tent.
-[laughter]
I'm gonna try and make my caramel oysters.
All I'm gonna do is spoon a wee bit in
and kind of work it up
the sides, effectively.
And that should give us a wee hemisphere.
We'll join the two together later
and we'll have an oyster.
These are just little fondant daisies.
Very springtime vibes.
[Noel] With proving time at a premium…
They're not as proved as I wish they were,
but I need to get them in.
…the bakers must decide
when to draw the line…
I'm gonna give them an extra five minutes.
…and when their bakes
are ready to hit the oven.
-Off you go.
-[Rebs] They're a bit flat.
I think I might be Mexican in my soul.
-Maybe you should join us and bake.
-I'm not sure about baking.
Never been sure about baking.
-Always seems like a waste of time to me.
-[both laugh]
-To be fair, yeah.
-I'm joking, I love baking.
[Maxy] I'm gonna put 'em in now.
-[Janusz] So now it's just baking.
-Some of them are better than others.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
[rattling]
Prue's earrings.
-I'll give them back to her.
-Yeah, please do.
[chuckles]
[Carole] I don't want them
overcooked 'cause they'll be dry.
And then I don't want them undercooked
and they'll be raw.
-Is that your own mortar and pestle?
-No. That's a big boy, that, isn't it?
When people say they like baking
and have those, I go, "Yeah."
-I've got one at home.
-"You're the real deal."
[Matt] For those who got bakes in early,
their pan dulce time is up.
[Sandro] Done. They're like little brains.
Could say I've done some Mexican brains.
It's come out pretty well.
Couple of cracks.
The sizes are roughly the same.
The pattern
I wish was more consistent across them.
It does look like corn.
That's what I'm happy with.
[Matt] The remaining bakers
face an anxious wait.
Do you think they're nearly ready? Ooh.
Ooh, a couple of them
have burst out the top.
-[Matt] While their rivals crack on…
-[Kevin] These bad boys are ready to soak.
[Matt] …with assembly…
[Abdul] I'm putting in
my white chocolate buttercream
and then there you go, they smooch
in like, "Mwah, mwah." [laughs]
[Matt] …glazes…
Generous portions.
Like a generous portion, I do. [chuckles]
…and decoration.
Oyster. Clam. I don't know.
I don't know seashells, do I?
How we doing for time?
Bakers, you have five minutes remaining.
Right, they're gonna come out. Grand.
[Noel] For those
with buns still in the oven…
Nice, good.
Now it needs to cool so I can decorate it.
…it's now or never.
They are looking baked.
Oh, no, they're burnt. They're burnt!
Oh, crap, right.
Oh! They're a bit hot.
-Are you worried about your crack?
-No, I'm gonna cover it.
It's better
when it's covered, the crack, isn't it?
He'll tell me they're overdone,
I know they are.
And also, the top bit didn't go so well.
C'est le vie.
[Sandro] Final touches.
[Kevin] So I'm gonna
paint some rum butter on.
I'm using a star tip nozzle
so that it doesn't look like a little poo.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
-[Maxy] What?
-That's not long enough.
Really? They're just gonna
have to go on here warm. Oh, my!
That one burst. Quite a few of them have.
[Janusz] I'm gonna pipe some icing.
[Rebs] I'm using this curd
to stick the daisies on.
[James] Oh, hot, oh, hot, oh, hot.
Turned out better than what I practised.
They look more expensive.
[Syabira] Oh, I need to arrange like corn
that is coming out from the field.
Oh, my God. Trying to compete
is impossible, those are absurd.
Bakers, your time is up.
[James] And breathe.
Please step away from your bakes.
[James] I'm quite proud
of these wee things.
Oh, they're a bit overbaked.
I'm happy with the bread,
to be fair, but they look shocking.
[Matt] The bakers' pan dulces
will now face the judgement
of Paul and Prue.
-Hello, Janusz.
-Hello.
Well, they look very even, nicely brown.
Like the craquelin on the top
and the way it's been cut.
The roll is pretty equal colour as well.
Let's see what it's like.
-This was done with plain flour?
-It was, yes.
I think you need more lime,
and the bun is quite dry.
[Paul] The texture's all right.
I'd like to have seen it more open
and that's because you used plain flour.
But the problem is for me,
it's not punching any flavours at all.
I like the look of them, though.
You know, I think
they look really interesting.
They look attractive,
make your mouth water, I want to eat it.
[Paul] Let's look inside.
I like the look of this. Lots of filling.
Love the flavour. It's under-proved.
Hugely under-proved.
It's so dense, it's almost dough-like.
[Prue] Do you know,
I think the flavour is fantastic.
It is a bit tight and stiff.
The overall look, awful.
Craquelin's not good.
-Looks like you sat on 'em.
-Oh, all right, it's killing me. Okay.
-[Prue] It's split, hasn't it?
-[Paul] Yeah.
The roll is okay.
Needed a bit more of a dome on it.
The colour looks nice.
The lemon in there's good.
The craquelin was too heavy.
Too thick, and then it's weighted it down
so the bread couldn't bloom.
But it's created quite a stretchy dough.
It's nicely-made bread.
-Just the craquelin's the problem.
-Yeah.
You're certainly showing off
your sugar craft skills.
[Paul] I love the top.
That top is, it's fantastic.
-Craquelin's definitely too thick.
-[Paul] Really dry because of it.
[Prue] Very dense.
Not a huge amount of flavour either.
Bit of kick in the craquelin.
If it's going to be as plain as that,
it needs a filling.
-They're not totally even in shape.
-[Carole] No.
[Paul] They're not really
Chelsea bun shape.
[Prue] It wouldn't matter
what shape they were
as long as they were all the same.
Lovely flavour.
I think the orange
and the anise comes through.
It's just, it's under-proved.
It's quite dense, but the taste is great.
The bread dough is a little heavy,
but the whole thing is delicious.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-[chuckles]
They look quite impressive, quite nice.
-They're glue.
-[Prue] They are cake-like.
-[Abdul] Mmm-hmm.
-Do you want a taste?
-[Abdul] Sure.
-[Paul] The flavours are quite delicate,
the raspberry and the coconut.
It sort of works.
I think it's too dense.
That, for me, is not right.
-It's not quite right.
-Okay.
I think they look absolutely beautiful.
They definitely look like corn.
They're clever. They do look pretty good.
What's inside it?
[Syabira] It's corn custard filling.
[Prue] That looks really good.
I love the flavour.
It's quite dry, but it's very interesting.
You added filling
before it went in the oven.
-Yes.
-[Paul] So it couldn't grow.
Then you had a craquelin on the top,
which prevents growth. So it stays solid.
So you end up with going back to dough.
Like the idea, though.
So I've made conchas,
the flavours I've used
are cinnamon and orange.
-They look even and big.
-[Paul] I like the look.
Yeah, I like the size. Could've done with
a bit more of a dome. You've got some.
You've got a bit of height there.
Craquelin's sitting quite nicely on it.
[Prue] The craquelin's really good.
It's a little bit crisper,
so you get that contrast.
That's good bread.
[Paul] Your flavour's nice.
I like the look of them.
You've got a real instinct
for what goes with what.
And I think
those are all beautiful flavours.
They're overbaked.
-You can see by the colour underneath.
-[Dawn] Yeah.
Size-wise, they're okay.
I'd like to have seen more of a dome.
You've lost that because of the filling.
The design's messy.
It's all over the place
because it's cracked coming through
and you've lost the definition.
Yeah. I didn't want it
to be a case of hunt the ganache.
But are we going to get
the promised chilli? That's the thing.
[Dawn] Not immediately.
You do get the chilli.
You're right, it comes later.
The chilli content in the chocolate
is perfect. Just the right amount.
-It's messy for me.
-Yes.
All over the place.
It's not tidy or accurate enough.
I agree.
I think it tastes good, textures are good.
-Doesn't look too good.
-No.
They look great. I like the look of them.
[Noel] They do look
like little drunk fellas.
[Paul] Could do with being
a bit more open.
-Another five-ten minutes proving.
-Okay.
[Paul] I really do like the flavour.
The dough is nearly there.
To be honest,
this is one of the best we've tasted.
It's all good.
Ten more minutes proving,
you'd have had perfection.
[sighs]
Yeah, it went pretty well.
Almost got a handshake. Stingy git.
I was so happy about the chilli.
And I was watching their faces,
all of a sudden they were like,
"Yes, the chilli is now creeping up."
Do you know, if I'm not
bottom two or three, I'd be happy.
I don't wanna say disastrous,
but borderline. [laughs]
[buzzing]
[Noel] While the bakers
practised their signatures,
they haven't a clue
what they'll be asked to make
in today's Mexican technical.
Bakers, it's time
for your technical challenge,
which today has been set by…
"Paul Hollywood."
Ring any bells?
Never heard of him.
So, er, Paul, any words of advice?
You've got to get
your flavour combinations right
and your textures.
As ever, the technical challenge
will be judged blind,
so we're gonna have to ask these two
to vacate the tent. Off you go.
-They're going to a soft play area.
-What, to go in the pit of balls?
-Yeah, Paul in the balls.
-Yeah.
For your technical challenge,
"Paul" would like you
to make eight Mexican tacos.
Your tacos
should be made from yellow field corn
and then hand pressed.
On top of each should be steak,
spicy refried beans,
guacamole and pico de gallo.
-[Noel] You have two hours.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake!
Well, this is gonna be interesting.
Tacos, new one on me.
I've never made 'em
from scratch before. Oh, no.
This is my first time doing tacos.
I bet it's the same like
you make tortillas.
I never made tortillas either.
Paul, tacos for a technical.
It's Mexican Week, Prue.
It has to be tacos.
[Prue] Tell me about the fillings then.
[Paul] You've got a pico de gallo
which is basically a salsa,
a guacamole, then the steak,
and a little bit of cheese,
and also refried beans.
I must say, it does look good.
And the big thing
is getting the taco right.
Thickness of the tortilla,
is it gonna be too thick or too thin,
and then the actual stage on the pan.
You only need
less than a minute on both sides.
If you do any more, it will dry out
and when you try
and roll it up into a taco, it will crack.
-It's got to be pliable.
-And they are very thin.
They are very thin,
and if it is thin, it will work.
One of the big things in Mexico
when you're having a taco,
it's lovely to have a lot of filling,
but it has to be practical too.
So you should be able to encase it
and then eat it.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-If it's too much, it'll go everywhere.
Okay, Prue.
-Choose your taco.
-[Prue] Okay. Okay.
-Hmm.
-[Paul] Wow.
Corn flavour
coming from the taco is perfect.
Blended with all the ingredients.
Overall, it's a delicious eat.
For me,
this is Mexican cooking on a plate.
-Can I have it for my lunch?
-[chuckles]
The instructions
aren't really that detailed.
For each element, it just says,
"Make the pico de gallo,
make the refried beans,
make the guacamole."
It's quite scant.
-Have you made, er, tacos--
-No. No.
Hang on. You don't know
what the question was gonna be.
So the first bit is, "For the tortillas,
blend the drained corn
until you have a smooth, thick paste."
"Tip the processed corn
out onto a work surface
and add masa harina,
then mix to form a dough."
Masa harina, I think it's like corn flour.
[Kevin] I'm not sure
how this dough's meant to look.
If it's corn, I don't suppose
it needs a lot of kneading.
Think it'll be sort of like
a thick bread-like dough texture.
-"Cover and leave to stand."
-"And let it rest. Don't touch it."
They want to be rested.
"Marinade the steak."
[Rebs] Nice steaks.
-Would you eat that like that?
-[Sandro] Never.
-I'm not really a raw, bloody meat person.
-No.
I cry when I eat a leaf.
So the ingredients
tell you what spices and herbs to use,
but they don't say how much.
Oh, my God, they don't give you
any teaspoonfuls or anything.
Ground cumin.
Smoked paprika, dried oregano.
[Dawn] Like a mad professor,
I am flinging things
into a bowl with gay abandon.
-Ancho chilli powder.
-[Kevin] Ancho chilli powder is dangerous.
So we will be going easy.
I just hope my, er, chilli is not too hot.
[Syabira] Something missing.
[exhales] I'm gonna sneeze in a sec.
You can't really taste this.
Blech! It's burning my mouth.
Well, it's meant to be hot anyway.
-It's meant to be Mexican, innit?
-Beef marinated.
[sneezes, sniffles]
Excuse me.
What's pico de gallo?
"Pico de gallio."
Interesting, pico de gallo.
First time I've heard them.
I think pico means small, maybe.
It's like a salsa,
just reading the ingredients.
White onion, very big white onion.
"Deseed and finely chop tomatoes."
[Carole] Deseed a tomato?
How do you deseed a tomato?
Chilli went in, coriander, juice, salt.
I could eat a tub of coriander by itself.
It's gorgeous.
I love coriander and cilantro.
I know people hate it.
Apparently, there's a gene
that makes you taste coriander like soap.
-It taste like soap.
-[Rebs] Everybody's got their own tastes.
I'm doing this to my taste,
but it might not be to Paul's.
Spicy, soapy, salty and sour. Great.
Noel, do you wanna hear my Mexican accent?
-Yes, please.
-All right, here we go.
[in normal voice] Arriba.
You are halfway through.
What do you reckon?
-It's really good.
-Thank you.
[laughing]
So to make the refried beans,
the instructions said,
"Make the refried beans."
I make kidney beans
at home with coconut milk.
So same method without coconut.
So I think we just fry them
with everything that's here.
I'm gonna fry onion with garlic.
I'm gonna add chilli powder,
salt, black beans.
Let's go half. Don't go mad, Carole.
This is really hot.
I don't think it's supposed to be hot.
And then this one
straight up won't turn on.
-You look like you're typing out an essay.
-[both laugh]
-What you trying to do?
-I'm trying to make it turn on.
-Is this the future champion?
-[laughing]
-[Noel] Oh!
-[timer beeping]
-Everything's happening at once.
-You're having a breakdown.
That's not even happening.
That's inside your head.
[Syabira] It's not that cooked,
so I'm just gonna simmer
and it'll get soft.
[Sandro] We'll let that thicken a bit.
[Carole] I have honestly
never made this, never.
-I'm gonna start making my guacamole now.
-"Step six, make guacamole."
[Carole] Now how many avocados
do we put in there? Oh, God.
Chopped tomatoes are going in.
Red onion. Jalapeños.
Juice of lime.
I like to have a little bit of chunk
'cause Paul said
it's about flavour and texture.
I, like, blitz the avocado
till it's smooth and creamy.
You're looking for smooth and chunky.
That's the best way.
-This is perfect for me.
-[Syabira] So my beans finish.
I think that's what
refried beans looks like.
Let me actually taste this.
Right amount of chilli in my opinion.
-It tastes okay.
-I might put some more salt.
I don't know if this is right.
-[Syabira] Oh, spicy.
-Not bad.
Noel, I absolutely insist
that you do this time call.
We've been down this road before.
No, no, I insist. I've got your back here.
Okay, off you go.
-Promise?
-Promise.
-Bakers--
-Bakers, you have half an hour left!
-Oh, my God.
-Here we go. "Make the tortillas."
"Divide the rested dough
into eight equal balls."
"Flatten using the lid
of a casserole dish."
"No tortilla press."
[James] Think we just kind of go…
Looks like what I'd imagine
you would get, doesn't it? [chuckles]
[grunts]
-[Syabira] My tortilla dance.
-I'm too small, I'm on tiptoe.
Slam it! [laughs]
I'm just gonna get it as flat as I can.
[grunts] This is the hardest part.
You don't know how thick
or how thin it should be.
[James] They don't seem to turn out
that big. Try and get it flatter.
They are small, but I guess
tacos are supposed to be small.
Ta-da! "Bite size,"
I think, is the correct term.
What next? "Cook the tortillas." [laughs]
Tortillas, traditionally, I think
are meant to be cooked on a hot stone.
-You just kind of go…
-[Sandro] So I'm going in.
Boop.
I'm thinking two minutes on each side.
[Janusz] One minute each side,
should be done.
Put it in a very high heat so it puff.
Puff, puff.
Oh, we have some puffing.
-Yes!
-[Carole] They're puffing now.
Is it meant to happen?
I don't wanna overcook 'em.
Why don't you just put that under there
and I'll go… As if I leant on it and…
Like in the Chuckle Brothers?
[chuckles] Shall we try?
-No.
-I need…
-You need them, don't you?
-I need these, yeah.
[Sandro] Two done.
I don't know
how they're meant to look exactly,
but I want some brown on there.
You don't want your tortilla
to be too dry. Not bad.
They've started cracking.
That's a problem.
Oh, no, this one's burnt.
This one's burnt. Ah.
And it's not puffing up.
[Carole] Do they look like a tortilla?
[laughing] Haven't got a clue.
-They're very small, aren't they?
-[Janusz] Last one. They look cooked.
There's so many things to go wrong. Ugh!
-[Noel] Okay, Matt.
-[Matt] Yeah.
-Let's turn the tables a bit.
-Okay.
-Why don't you do a time call?
-And I won't interrupt you or anything.
-Okay.
-You just do it.
-You sure?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
Weren't you supposed to interrupt me?
-Yeah.
That's all my tacos done.
Just need to make steak now.
[Janusz] The plan is to fry the steak.
Medium rare.
Straight in.
[in American accent] Nice and sizzly.
That looks like expensive meat actually.
Which is weird
'cause we found that in a skip.
-[laughs]
-I'm joking.
[hums] I don't know how to cook steak.
I would cook it
about five minutes each side.
Couple of minutes on each side.
If I've got time.
Everyone's got an opinion on steak
and everyone thinks you've done it wrong.
[Maxy] I could go longer,
but I'm scared to overcook it.
I'll give it another 30 seconds.
-[Syabira] Nice pink in the middle.
-[Dawn] That's still mooing.
[Maxy] It's all right.
[Rebs] Oh, Maxy,
your steak's cooked perfectly.
My steak's gonna be hot.
I wouldn't eat it.
-[chuckles]
-[Sandro laughs]
-How long do we have?
-Bakers, you have five minutes left.
-Do we? Okay. [laughs]
-Just gonna start assembling.
What goes first? Hmm.
-Bit of steak.
-[Syabira] And then the fried beans.
Just don't know how much of each to use.
I won't put that much in.
-Wee forkful of each.
-Holy guacamole.
-Where to put the guacimolo?
-Salsa?
[Rebs] My pico de gallo's a bit spicy.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Oh, my gosh.
-[Abdul] This is gonna be so tight.
-Oh, now I'm in panic mode.
Cheesy stuff, throw it on.
[Rebs] Don't forget the cheese.
[Abdul] I have one more to go.
[Kevin] These are quite stuffed.
I wish that we'd had,
like, quantities. Oh, well.
-[Maxy] Trying to make the board pretty.
-[Sandro] It's a bit fiddly.
-[Kevin] Best way for me to use avocado.
-[sighs]
[Carole] That's, erm, small.
Bakers, your time is up.
Bring your tacos down to the table
and place them
in front of your photograph.
[sighs] Wow.
[Janusz] I wish I could try one.
I go there and then… thingy can go there.
[Matt] Paul and Prue
are looking for eight thin tortillas
topped with perfectly marinated steak,
spicy refried beans,
pico de gallo, and a tangy guacamole.
[Prue breathes deeply]
[Paul] There's a bit of a difference
in thickness and size.
-It's so tempting to put too much filling.
-Yes. It is.
[chuckles] Right, let's start over here.
These are actually quite neat.
-They look very nice, don't they?
-[Paul] Nice fill, that one, as well.
It's just about right.
-Have to have a big gob, you know.
-I know.
[Prue] You really
want to get it all in at once.
Hmm.
That's pretty good. It's balanced well.
The heat in it is about right.
And I love the fact
that the meat is nice and rare.
[Paul] A bit of colour on this.
There's no need for colour.
A bit of darkness in some of these,
but the majority are all right.
-Yeah, I think it's lovely.
-[Paul] Moving on to number two.
-These look dry, see the crack.
-[Prue] They look a bit crisp.
[Paul] It's been overcooked
or there isn't enough water.
[Prue] Let's taste it.
-Hmm, that is good.
-[Paul] Steak is spot on. Filling's okay.
[Prue] There's slightly too much onion
and slightly too much chilli, but…
-Hmm.
-Everything else is wonderful.
[Paul] Okay, moving on.
-Now these…
-[Prue] A little too full, isn't it?
Yeah. For the size of them.
Little bit thick as well actually.
They're very small.
I'm… I'm getting slightly
over-seasoned, a bit salty.
I'll tell you where there's too much salt.
In the taco.
[Paul] They're a little bit dry.
You wouldn't expect them to be that dry.
Moving on.
The feathering round the outside,
they should be beautifully round.
They're all over the place.
This is quite a dry one as well.
That cow's still mooing.
-[Prue] I like the flavour.
-Yeah.
-Right.
-[Paul] These look quite pale.
-Almost underdone.
-It's also got too much filling, I think.
[Paul] I think there is.
-Again, quite salty, isn't it?
-[Prue] It's very well-seasoned.
-Even too much.
-[Paul] Too much.
Now, these are too small.
That's ridiculously thick.
There isn't as much seasoning in that one,
but the meat's cooked well. Moving on.
-[Prue] They look quite thin.
-[Paul] They've been cooked quite nicely.
-And I quite like that--
-But that fits nicely.
-Yeah, and there's not too much in it. So…
-Yeah.
Taco's good. Meat, tick. Guac, tick.
And the pico's nice as well.
-It works as a taco.
-[Prue] Hmm.
[Paul] Oh, dear. Far too thick.
Far, far too thick.
-[Prue] Too much chilli.
-[Paul] Too thick.
The meat needs to be cut smaller
on something so dainty and small.
[Prue] Okay, this is the right size.
-[Paul] These here are cracked, see?
-[Prue] Yeah.
[Paul] They've overdone 'em.
[Prue] Mmm-hmm.
The guacamole's very nice.
The beef's nice and rare.
[Paul] The flavour's okay,
but the taco's overcooked.
[Prue] Last one.
[Paul] These are quite delicate tortillas.
[Prue] Yeah, they're thin.
That's a good one.
Guacamole's excellent. I really like that.
[Paul] The tacos are nice.
Not getting much chilli.
-[Prue] No.
-Okay.
[Noel] Prue and Paul will now
rank the tacos from worst to first.
In tenth place, we have this one.
Carole, not very good,
very thick, too small.
Ninth spot, we have this one.
Whose is this?
Rebs, basically over-seasoned,
massively over-seasoned
and too much filling in there.
In eighth place, we've got this one.
James, the tacos are just slightly small.
[Noel] Janusz is seventh, Abdul is sixth,
Dawn is fifth, and Kevin is fourth.
In third spot, we have this one.
Whose is this?
Sandro, actually, these were pretty good.
Could've been a little neater.
This is number two.
Over here.
Syabira, these were really delicious,
except that they were
a little bit difficult to manage
because they were breaking up.
-In first spot, we have this one.
-[applause]
[laughter]
Beautifully filled, taco was really good,
seasoning very good as well. Well done.
Thank you.
I feel over the moon, honestly.
I feel over the moon. I didn't expect it.
Second for the taco? Yes!
I'm pretty chuffed with myself
for my performance today.
So, came in eighth in the technical,
which is better than I thought.
But worse than I would hope. [laughs]
[indistinct chatter]
[sighs] I'm a little bit
disappointed in the result.
The pressure is on for tomorrow now.
If I don't do well tomorrow,
I'll be packing my suitcase.
[Matt] Only the showstopper
challenge remains
before Paul and Prue decide
who will be leaving the tent
and who has scooped Star Baker.
Hello, bakers, welcome back to the tent.
Now, for your
Mexican showstopper challenge,
the judges would like you
to create your own take
on the popular tres leches cake.
Now, tres leches
obviously refers to the three milks
that are traditionally used
to soak the sponge once its baked.
You can use
any combination of flavours you like,
but your cake must consist
of at least four layers
of milk-soaked sponge.
Your tres leches cake needs to be bold,
delicious, and inspired by Mexico.
You have four hours.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
Bake.
I love a tres leches. My favourite thing
is that it's full of moisture.
A tres leches cake
basically means three-milk cake.
Evaporated milk,
condensed milk, and double cream.
I never tried tres leches cake before.
[Prue] Put all these milks together,
make a syrup of it,
make lots of holes in the cake
and pour the syrup all over.
And that soaks in
and allows the cake to really moisten up.
[Prue] What it mustn't do
is to so sog up the cake
that the milks
are running out of the bottom.
So it's gonna have to be layers
of moist cake one on top of another.
This is tricky.
The difficulty
we're all gonna face is the soak.
[Paul] Because the cakes are so moist,
when they lift the cake,
it could fall apart.
If it's too soaked structurally,
it might break,
and if it's not enough soak,
then is it really tres leches?
A fine balance over there.
Obviously, we want high decoration,
it's a showstopper.
And they do have four hours.
I mean, a Mexican cake,
above all, looks fantastic.
It's one of my favourite cakes.
It's beautiful.
-[judges] Good morning.
-Good morning.
Tell us about your tres leches cake.
-It's a…
-[snaps fingers]
-…fiesta kind of cake.
-[laughter]
So I'll have a big moustache in the middle
and at the bottom
going around will have iced biscuits.
[Matt] Enveloped in a decorative
white chocolate collar,
Sandro's cakes include
a chilli chocolate coffee sponge
with Irish cream soak
and a spiced chocolate sponge
with coffee and cherry brandy soak.
That sounds amazing.
-It did taste nice. Was very adult type.
-[Paul] Yeah.
-Chocolate, coffee…
-[Prue] Grown-up cake.
-…chilli.
-Yeah.
It's got four teaspoons of chilli flakes.
Interesting.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-[Prue] Thanks, Sandro.
I got a face when I said
there's four teaspoons of chilli,
so I hope it isn't overpowering.
[Noel] Sandro's not the only baker
in the party mood.
-[Paul] Morning, Maxy.
-Good morning.
Tell us about your tres leches cake.
Cake is called Cocoa Flower Fiesta.
I'm making a chocolate tres leches cake
filled with strawberries and cream
and the outside
will be decorated with flowers.
[Noel] Maxy's chocolate sponge
will have a tres leches vanilla soak,
layers of strawberries,
Italian meringue buttercream,
and cinnamon vanilla cream.
-Going to be so rich.
-Very rich.
-[Prue] It'll be so rich.
-Is it still nice and light though?
Ah, I hope so.
Well, good luck, Maxy.
[Matt] Abdul is also
opting for a celebration,
one with a uniquely Mexican vibe.
Theme is Day of the Dead.
-Oh, yes.
-I'm making white chocolate skulls.
Love Day of the Dead.
Glad someone's doing it.
[Matt] Abdul's cake will be soaked
in passion fruit and coconut tres leches,
have lime curd filling,
and be adorned
with white chocolate sugar skulls.
It's Day of the Dead.
Want me to get you some poison?
I think on the Day of the Dead,
you honour those who have passed away
rather than make more people--
-Make them pass.
-Yes.
-All right. Noted. Noted.
-I think that's the concept. Yeah.
[chuckles]
[Noel] The bakers
may use any sponge they choose…
Angel cake. It's a fat-less cake.
I'm doing a whisked sponge.
…and Syabira's
opted for the unconventional.
-I am making, erm, sweetcorn sponge.
-Explain.
It's a sponge
that I put a little bit of sweetcorn in.
Why would you want that in a cake?
-I like the idea of it.
-Well, it's very Mexican.
-[Syabira chuckles]
-And it might work.
[Noel] Syabira's sweetcorn sponge
will be soaked
with a sweetcorn tres leches,
filled with creamed corn
and cinnamon-flavoured cream cheese icing.
So you wanna celebrate
the taste of sweetcorn.
Which is quite difficult to bring through
considering it'll be fighting
with other flavours as well.
-[Noel] I love sweetcorn.
-[chuckles] Thank you.
[Noel] Don't look so stressed.
This sounds good.
-Thanks.
-I hope it works.
You're off your maracas.
[Noel laughing]
[Rebs] I tried getting in
as much Mexican flavour as I can.
Gonna bring good vibes, good energy.
Gonna go okay today. I'm not going home.
[Matt] After another set
of poor performances,
Rebs is determined to deliver a winner.
So I am doing a tiramisu
tres leches wedding cake.
So it's a wedding cake
to symbolise the marriage
between an Italian classic
and Mexican flavours.
-[Prue] Okay.
-Okay.
[Noel] Swapping Italian Marsala wine
for Mexican,
Rebs' cake
will get a coffee tres leches soak
and a trio of fillings,
including a chilli chocolate ganache.
It's all about marketing,
you see. Branding.
If I say it's a wedding cake,
then it's allowed to be more simple.
[Noel] The judges have asked
for a minimum of four layers of sponge.
I think it was quite mean.
Tres leches sponge is not for stacking.
[Noel] Despite this, Kevin is undertaking
a vast geometric construction.
My tres leches sponge
will be soaked in coffee milk
and I'll be building it
in four square tins
to make an Aztec pyramid temple.
Mayan or Aztec?
-There's a bit of overlap, isn't there?
-[laughter]
[Noel] Kevin's
Central American-style pyramid
will have a coffee tres leches soak,
be filled with hazelnut praline cream,
and coated with a chocolate ganache
that comes with a kick.
Got some chilli in the ganache.
Hopefully not too much.
Don't want the judges
to feel like they're eating electricity.
-I'd like you to take their heads off.
-I would like to not go home.
-Okay, well, let's meet in the middle.
-[laughs]
[Matt] To make a four-tier cake
requires vast amounts
of smooth well-mixed batter.
[James] I think this batter
actually looks quite good.
It looks quite light and fluffy.
[Matt] And multiple tins that somehow
need to be squeezed in the oven.
[Rebs] Trying to
get them in at the same time.
There you go, sponges going in.
Thirty minutes in the oven
and hopefully they will be baked.
[Sandro] Bake beautifully.
[Dawn] So these are going in now.
Lovely.
Just making the milk soak now.
[Matt] The bakers can now create
what is the key
to a good tres leches cake.
Whipping cream, evaporated milk, coconut.
[Maxy] I'm using 300 ml of double cream.
Same for the evaporated milk
and condensed milk.
I'm putting some Mexican coffee liqueur
and now some tequila.
[Noel] Determined
to celebrate Mexican flavours…
Chocolate, coffee,
little bit of chilli in it, orange, lime.
…Carole's cake
will include more than a few.
Bit of a mixture really.
[Noel] Carole's chocolate cake
will get a coffee liqueur soak,
lemon and orange buttercreams,
be surrounded by a chocolate collar,
and come topped with chocolate flowers
and hazelnut caramel spikes.
Are we playing into your strengths here?
-I do like decorating cakes.
-The idea of the collar sounds good.
-Hope you get it all finished on time.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[Matt] The coffee and chocolate combo
is proving popular.
I've got coffee in here
and I've got a dark chocolate
feuilletine layer,
and that just gives it
a bit of crunch in this very wet thing.
[Matt] Dawn's sponges will be soaked
with vanilla-flavoured tres leches
filled with a coffee crème mousseline
and topped with a bunch of choux buns
filed with an amaretto crème pat.
So there's some booze
in the profiteroles if you want it.
I've decided to celebrate,
er, fruits of Mexico.
[Noel] Rather than booze,
Janusz is choosing the healthy option.
[Janusz] I'm gonna use
tiny bit of lemon, dragon fruit,
passion fruit, guava,
and I've got mango in the freezer.
I knew I'm missing one. [chuckles]
[Noel] His dragon fruit cake
will have a guava and coconut milk soak,
mango cream and dragon fruit
and passion fruit curd.
Your whole idea of this cake
sounds amazing.
It's challenging for yourself,
which is good.
You've been Star Baker
a couple of times now.
-Lovely idea.
-Thank you so much.
Always something interesting
going on with you.
[Syabira] Soak completed.
[Matt] In addition to their soak,
the bakers must create fillings
that balance the sweet-rich sponge.
Coconut dacquoise.
[Matt] And a number of them
are risking a powerful Mexican flavour.
I've already put
one teaspoon of chilli powder
and one teaspoon of the chilli flakes.
Need to add the chilli in.
I don't want the judges choking on it,
but I don't want them to say,
"Oh, can't really get the chilli."
[Carole] Bird's eye chillies.
Oh, flipping hell, that's strong.
[laughs]
[Noel] Also embracing chilli…
[James] Doesn't this look delightful?
…after a poor showing
in the challenges so far,
James aims to make up ground
with multiple elements.
It's a chocolate,
chilli, and lime tres leches cake
and the top tier
is gonna be a fraisier tart.
To neaten up around the outside
I have a white chocolate collar.
[Matt] Going all out,
James' lemon and lime sponges
will have a vanilla tres leches soak,
dulce de leche lime curd,
and crème diplomat fillings.
The cake will be coated
in chilli chocolate ganache
and be topped with
a strawberry fraisier tart and cookies.
-James, you have got a lot to do.
-Lot of work.
Quite a lot for four hours.
That's a huge task,
but if you pull it off…
I need to this week.
[laughing] It's not been my week so far.
Bakers, you're halfway through!
I reckon that's cooked.
[Dawn] They're looking all right.
[Noel] With sponges out the oven…
[exhales]
…getting the soak in is critical.
[Janusz] As usual,
I'm gonna cut the tops off.
I'm the queen of cutting tops off cakes.
Gonna prick the tops of them
and get some lovely milk into them.
[Noel] To ensure each bite is
decadently moist, needs liberal soaking.
You need to get it wet enough
that it's, like, soaked,
but not wet enough
that it's going to ooze.
[Matt] But overdo it…
[Dawn] That's a lot of soak gone in there.
[Matt] …and the sponges
will be impossible to assemble…
What you don't want
is it to be really saturated
or the whole cake'll collapse.
…while scrimping on the soak means
the sponge will be dry and unpleasant.
[Janusz] I've used 500 ml for my one.
It's actually more than enough
because they are drinking quite quickly.
Trouble is, with an angel cake,
it's not brilliant at soaking in.
I'm just gonna
pop it in the fridge for a little while.
[Noel] As soaked sponges go in to set,
the bakers turn their attention
to coating their cakes.
Lime butter icing.
Sugar, sugar, sugar, sugar, sugar. 392.
[gasps] It's 392, innit? You daft cow.
And now I'm making
an Italian meringue buttercream.
Just putting the custard
into my German buttercream.
It's really delicious.
Not as sweet as normal buttercream.
Oh, wait.
Oh, that'll be burnt.
[Abdul] My Italian buttercream meringue
looks a bit split,
so I'm trying to whisk it
to see if it helps. We'll see.
[chuckles]
Just missed my,
er, caramel burning quite severely.
-I saw it and I smelt it.
-[laughs]
[Noel] As ever,
the judges are expecting the cakes
to not only be delicious,
but visually spectacular.
Gonna melt down some chocolate,
and that's gonna be a medallion
on top of the temple.
It's a temple to chocolate
made out of chocolate.
[Dawn] They're tiny baby choux.
Trouble is, if they're too small,
you can't fill them very easily.
My cake itself is called Day of the Dead.
I'm now melting
white chocolate to make my skulls.
It's overrated, being dead, I tell you.
I've been dead for 13 years now.
Paul has to break me out the cemetery
before every show.
-[chuckles]
-Prue puts clothes on me.
-Prue puts clothes on you?
-Prue dresses me like a dolly.
-I'm gonna get my curd from the fridge.
-I won't be here when you're back.
-I'll be in the graveyard.
-[Abdul] All right.
-I love you.
-I love you as well. [chuckles]
So let me get this straight.
Mexico is a real place.
-Yeah.
-How would one get there?
Oh, it's easy.
You just go like this… [whistles]
Well, that's all well and good for him,
but I can't do that.
[sighs] Bakers, you have one hour left!
-One--
-[whistles]
We are going to construct.
[Matt] It's now the bakers find out
if they have
one of two very different problems.
Oh, this is the stressful part.
[Matt] If their sponge is too wet,
it's at risk of collapse.
Cake. Soaked the whole way through.
Kind of what I hoped for.
[Matt] Too dry,
and it could fail to deliver
the sumptuous
tres leches eating experience.
I don't think it's soaked at all.
And soak, yeah.
[James] Ah, it's not centred.
Ah! Knew this would happen.
But do you know what? Go hard or go home.
[Maxy] Oh.
I just don't want it to collapse.
I doubt this is how
the Aztecs originally built it.
I think a lot more engineering
would've gone into it.
The cake itself, it didn't soak well.
Oh, it's dry. I'm gonna cry.
[sniffles]
-[Abdul] It's gonna be all right.
-[chuckles]
It's gonna be all right, okay?
You'll pull this off.
-Your flavours are gonna be amazing.
-[sniffles]
[Noel] Building a multi-layered cake
with soaked sponges
is a construction conundrum.
[Abdul] I'm using supporting dowels.
[chuckles]
I think it would be absolute folly
not to dowel and board it.
Yeah. Gonna play it safe.
Make good decisions, Kevin.
Make good choices.
Oh, dear.
-Oh.
-[Noel] What's wrong?
I'm trying to deflower.
I won't get these off in time.
If you really concentrate,
you can slow time down.
Okay, all right.
-[Noel] Stressing you out, this talk?
-Oh, look at that.
I feel like my presence is making this
-much worse, isn't it?
-[chuckles]
[Rebs] My chocolate cake's split
at the bottom and is leaking everywhere.
I don't understand
why it's turned out like this.
I'm gonna try and cover it up with icing.
It's very difficult to get it…
Like, it's not working out that well.
Why is it so bulged this side?
My goodness, I'm gonna cry.
Just gotta get the cream on
and then I'll tidy it up.
It's a mess. Not good.
[Rebs] So frickin' stressed right now.
I love a good drip
because it hides all the ugly sides.
You can hide everything.
The cake is not right. The, ah…
[Sandro] Okay, chill out.
Oh, my goodness, this is so bad.
It's cracked!
This ain't even flipping working.
It's holding up well,
but, er, it's a mess.
This is not how this was supposed to go.
I don't wanna go home.
[Matt] Bakers.
-You have…
-Fifteen…
Minutes left.
Pew-pew. Oh.
-[Dawn] Need to get a wriggle on.
-[James] Oh, did not think this through.
A wee bit of piping
will cover up the flaws.
[Carole] We're all in a bleeding rush.
-You can do one flick. Last minute.
-That's what.
Go on.
I'm just trying
to make it look half presentable.
Oh!
Not a bit of milk left
in the bottom of this cake.
How long more do we have?
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
Oh, God.
[sighs] I just want something out there.
Oh.
[Sandro] Right, let's do the 'tache.
[James] Oh, cover the holes
with fun piping
and make it look like a natural look.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away
from your tres leches cakes.
I'm stepping away.
[laughs]
[sighs] It's four hours bake.
You won't make it perfect, will you?
[exhales]
It's so messy. I'm literally about to cry.
[Matt] The bakers' tres leches cakes
will now face the judgement
of Paul and Prue.
Your decoration is so accurate
and beautiful and piping is so good.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Let's have a look.
I think the soak's a bit dry
on a couple of them.
-Top two seems wetter than the bottom.
-I agree.
Mmm.
[chuckles]
It's such a surprise.
It tastes likes sweetcorn.
[laughs]
It does, yeah.
I mean, we asked you to be imaginative.
Well, that is imaginative.
It's not for me.
My only quarrel
is I think it would've been better
not to have the lumps of corn in the cake
'cause it spoils the texture.
But it was a really good original cake.
Well done, Syabira.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Thank you.
I think, overall, you attempted too much.
-None of it's neat enough.
-Hmm.
The fraisier cake needs to be much neater.
The collar has lost all its shine.
The pipe work isn't particularly good.
-I have a few issues with this.
-[Prue] It is a bit untidy.
But let's see what it tastes like.
[Matt] Well, it does look good.
Hmm. The cake layer
is absolutely delicious.
I like the flavour of the fraisier tart.
Creaminess, the lightness, the vanilla.
The top sponge is a bit tough.
Much drier than the bottom one.
The bottom layer is the chilli one?
I've got a lime curd
and a crème pat in it.
[Prue] The sponge is good,
but it is unevenly soaked.
I like the lime curd and the sponge,
but it is messy.
Thank you.
Well, I must say I love the idea.
Icing is a little rough and ready.
Some of the milky syrup is running out,
which must mean it's quite well-soaked.
Maybe over-soaked.
[Paul] I think the design is fantastic
and to make it
in tres leches cake is tricky.
You've pulled it off all right.
What's that in the bottom,
is it where the milks haven't soaked in?
[Kevin] There's probably
a few parts where it's not soaked in.
[Prue] I love the flavour.
It's got a little bit of a kick.
Quite a kick. It's strong chilli.
It's quite pungent,
and the biggest issue
I have is the texture.
-You've got flour lumps in there.
-[Prue] Yeah.
A real pity because flavour's good.
We asked for vibrant colour
and we've got it,
and I love the look of it.
I think the cake is quite effective.
Your colours are strong.
I like the decoration on top,
but let's see what it looks like inside.
-[Matt] Ooh.
-[Noel] Wow.
The bit of cake I've just got
doesn't seem to have been soaked at all.
-Have you got chilli in there?
-Yeah, in the ganache.
-Is it too strong?
-Yes. [laughs]
[Prue and Carole laugh]
When I put it in my mouth,
I was like, "What is that?"
You've added a punch
and a punch and a punch and a punch
-and then destroyed what it actually was.
-Hmm.
I think your criticism is too strong.
I think it's a really well-made cake.
A good job with the look.
I thought your flavours were too much.
Yeah.
I think it looks lovely.
Quite cartoon-like, but highly effective.
-The drips are perfect.
-[Prue] I think it's beautifully executed.
It's as neat as a pin
and it's very modern-looking.
Look at that. [chuckles]
How about that for colour?
Cake is quite dense.
The sponge is a little too dry.
You could've got more soak in there.
But your saving grace
is the guava and the passion fruit.
I would agree.
It looks absolutely wonderful.
The flavour's fantastic. I just think
that the cake is a little too firm.
[Paul] I think the skulls work.
Day of the Dead, celebration.
It's a little bit wonky.
I agree it's on the lean.
But I think it's an attractive,
unusual-looking cake.
Very even layers.
[Paul] The soak's gone through.
Quite nicely on each.
-The passion fruit and the lime…
-[Prue] Mmm, is lovely.
…work really nicely together.
You've done a decent job.
Sandro, I absolutely love the look of it.
It is a bit wonky.
It is wonky on the top,
which winds me up a bit,
but I love the colours.
It looks very good.
Right.
[Sandro] The bottom tier
is a chocolate coffee cake.
The top is a spiced chocolate cake
with spiced chocolate ganache
and cherry compote.
[Paul] It looks like
a black forest gateau actually.
[Prue] Mmm.
I know we always ask for strong flavours,
but I think you've overdone it a bit.
There's too much booze,
too much chilli, too much cherry.
A bit milder,
the bottom one, so it works nicer.
-[Sandro] Thank you.
-[Prue] That bottom layer is delicious.
I think it's something
of a little triumph.
So I have done a tres leches wedding cake,
a rustic wedding cake.
-It is rustic. You're right.
-[Rebs] Yeah.
[Paul] Bit of leakage down there as well.
[Prue] That is very boozy.
[Paul coughs]
-Have you got chilli in that ganache?
-Yeah.
[chuckling] Wow.
It's supposed to be mellowed by the cream.
[coughing] Filling is too much.
Little less tequila
and quite a lot less chilli.
-[Paul] You get hit with big flavours.
-[Prue] Hmm.
If you'd held back,
you'd have had an all-round nicer cake.
The overall look is good.
Your piping work,
the way it all cascades down looks great.
[Prue] Yes, I like it. I love the colours.
[Paul] Cuts nice.
Oh, that's interesting.
The buttercream's got a nice lightness
to go with the richness of the cake.
The chocolate flavour
comes through nicely.
So between the two,
it's quite stark but it works.
[Prue] You've done a good job, Maxy.
It looks simple and effective.
Quite elegant.
Let's see what it looks like inside.
Wow, that's soft.
That's heaven.
That flavour is heaven.
I like the crunch, I like the soft cake.
That's good.
-The sponge is so soft.
-[Prue] Hmm.
-[Paul] The coffee levels are perfect.
-[Prue] Wow.
[Paul] It's really good.
[Dawn] Thank you very much.
[applause]
I can't believe that.
-Absolutely stunned.
-Everything they said was fair.
Clumps of flour in your cake batter
just isn't acceptable.
[Sandro] She said it's a triumph.
"Triumph." That's a… That's a good word.
[Carole] If you went to put a bet on me,
I think I'd give myself seven to one.
My chances ain't very good.
[James] I think
I'm definitely in the firing line.
They asked for Mexican
and I feel it was more of a Mexi-can't.
[laughing]
We didn't get the Mexican weather.
It's been pretty cold again.
But we had some good Mexican showstoppers.
[Noel] They looked beautiful.
[Prue] They looked Mexican.
Lots of bright colours.
There's two people
that pull themselves up quite a bit
and I think Abdul and Dawn…
Dawn smashed it.
Both of them catapulted themselves up.
[Prue] What she was so clever about
is she wasn't over-complicating anything.
Then you look at the other side
of the coin, James, what was that about?
He stretched himself too much.
That fraisier cake was not good.
-And the collar was dull, it was matte.
-And it was very clumsy.
Too many elements.
But I'd say exactly the same about Carole.
[Matt] Coming into today,
Carole was near the bottom.
For me, she still is.
The other person in trouble was Rebs
and I think she still is.
Those cakes were far too strong.
-[gasps] Everything was too strong.
-We could get rid of two today.
There is legitimate reason.
To be honest,
we had three pretty poor performances
from Carole, Rebs, and James.
Has Dawn done enough with the showstopper
to be a consideration for Star Baker?
Without a shadow of a doubt,
Dawn's pushed herself up.
-Not quite in line with Star Baker.
-Right.
I think Maxy is, I think Sandro is.
-Yeah.
-And Janusz.
You have to put Janusz in as well.
Hello, bakers. Well done again
on that showstopper, it was amazing.
Luckily this week,
I've got the fabulous job
of announcing
which one of you has won Star Baker.
And the person
who is Star Baker this week is…
Maxy.
-[Janusz] Yeah!
-[applause]
-[laughter]
-Good girl.
I have the less fun job
of saying who's leaving us.
And yes, this week it is two bakers.
So the two bakers
who are leaving us this week are…
James… and Rebs.
[Carole sighs]
[indistinct chatter]
Honestly, devastated.
This means the world to me.
Sorry, Rebs. It's hard in this tent.
-It's only cake.
-[Rebs sobs]
[Prue] Poor Rebs.
Her flavours were just too strong
and too many of them.
Bake Off's been a fabulous experience.
I just didn't want it cut this short.
I'm gutted for James as well.
James is such a fabulous person.
It's been fun though,
so I don't mind. [laughs]
I'm always sad to see any bakers go,
but particularly James.
To use a fun metaphor,
I think I was a plant
that fruits were outgrowing its pot.
I'm going to really miss you, mate.
James had a rotten week.
His showstopper was a real disappointment.
Oh, I think I went wrong
across the board. [laughs]
I think Maxy winning Star Baker
for the second time is well-deserved.
She was the most consistent
over the three challenges.
I'm dancing right now. [laughs]
Just keep going, huh?
This has given me confidence, honestly.
I never thought I'd come to the tent
and get two Star Bakers. It's crazy.
[Paul] Next week, we're halfway through.
We've got five bakers in there
that are all doing very well.
There's another three of them
that have to step up
and show us what they really can do.
There's only one way this is gonna go
and it's, like, harder and harder.
[closing theme music playing]